[Music]
which is the hardest word to translate
in this sentence no is easy to translate
pep-rally doesn't have a direct analog
in a lot of languages and cultures but
can be approximated but the hardest word
there is actually one of the smallest
you as simple as it seems it's often
impossible to accurately translate you
without knowing a lot more about the
situation where it's being said to start
with how familiar are you with the
person you're talking to many cultures
have different levels of formality a
close friend someone much older or much
younger a stranger a boss these all may
be slightly different use in many
languages the pronoun reflects these
differences through what's known as the
t.v distinction in French for example
you would say to when talking to your
friend at school but who when addressing
your teacher even English once had
something similar remember the old tiny
thou ironically it was actually the
informal pronoun for people you're close
with while you was the formal and polite
version that distinction was lost when
the English decided to just be polite
all the time but the difficulty in
translating you doesn't end there
in languages like house' or karana the
you form depends on the listeners gender
in many more it depends on whether they
are one or many such as with german do
or ear even in english some dialects use
words like ya'll or use the same way
some plural forms like the French vous
and Russian V are also used for a single
person to show that the addressee is
that much more important much like the
Royal we and a few languages even have a
specific form for addressing exactly to
people like slovenian vive if that
wasn't complicated enough formality
number and gender can all come into play
at the same time in Spanish too is
unisex informal singular who
dead is unisex formal singular vosotros
is masculine informal plural vosotras is
feminine informal plural and aesthetics
is the unisex formal plural who after
all that it may come as a relief that
some languages often leave out the
second person pronoun in languages like
Romanian and Portuguese the pronoun can
be dropped from sentences because it's
clearly implied by the way the verbs are
conjugated and in languages like Korean
Thai and Chinese pronouns can be dropped
without any grammatical hints speakers
often would rather have the listener
guessed the pronoun from context than
use the wrong one and risk being seen as
rude so if you're ever working as a
translator and come across this sentence
without any context you and you know not
you you your job is to translate you for
yourselves well good luck and to the
volunteer community who will be
translating this video into multiple
languages sorry about that
[Music]
you